believe it or not the styles we know and
love as Marvel's mightiest heroes
weren't always the studio's first choice
assembling the right cast for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe was a Nick Fury sized
task that took years and still Marvel
couldn't get their top picks all of the
time
here are some actors who were almost
cast as an Avenger Sam Rockwell as Iron
Man Iron Man director Jon Favreau has
publicly acknowledged that the quirky
character actor was someone he's
seriously considered for Tony Stark
Favreau told hero complex he was one of
the actors I was looking out for Tony
Stark of course when I met with Robert
there was nobody else on my mind
Favreau liked to rock well so much that
he cast him in Iron Man 2 as Justin
Hammer a guy who really really wishes he
was Tony Stark
it's an Iron Man doll it's my nephew
Timmy's Timmy looks up to you
he wants to be you don't disappoint him
Timothy Olyphant
as Iron Man Holly Flint has headlined
both Deadwood and justified two beloved
critically acclaimed TV series but he
was looking to take his film career up a
notch his management team was able to
get him onto Jon Favreau shortlist for
Ironman its auditions went well and he
even filmed a screen test but due to
poor timing it didn't work out in his
favor a wonderful actor Robert Downey
jr. and I we screened tested on the same
day and I'm still waiting to hear back
and Eliza Dushku as Black Widow best
known for her roles and cult TV shows
like Joss Whedon's Safi The Vampire
Slayer and dollhouse - ku publicly
campaigned for the role of Black Widow
in Iron Man - she appeared on the Howard
Stern Show to specify exactly why she
wanted the role I just watched Iron Man
recently a Robert Downey jr. so hot and
they're doing Iron Man 2 and I am so
perfect for the Black Widow character
need to get into it I need to understand
she also added that she'd learned a lot
of Russian for an episode of dollhouse
which would come in handy playing the
Russian character even though she was a
Josh Whedon favorite the role went to
Scarlett Johansson Emily Blunt sus Black
Widow the British star of The Devil
Wears Prada was also one of Marvel's top
choices to play Black Widow in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the studio was
reportedly very close to signing her
until everyone realized a scheduling
conflict that couldn't be overcome her
starring role in the 2010 adaptation of
Gulliver
travels with Jack Black which was a
critical disaster John Krasinski as
Captain America coincidentally emily
Blunt's husband John Krasinski of the
office was very close to portraying
squeaky-clean all-american good guy
Steve Rogers and his alter ego Captain
America in 2010 news outlets reported
that he was very close to signing on the
dotted line but that wasn't quite true
as Krasinski relayed on Conan in 2016 I
was putting on the suit just watching I
was like this is so amazing and I got
about right to my waist that was still
shirtless the only pretty good about
myself wasn't 13 hours yet but night
felt pretty good and all of a sudden
Chris Hemsworth walked by his door and
he's like by night and I went I'm good
this is stupid
still it seems like he's settle for the
next best thing look everyone it's watch
spider-man and John Krasinski all right
great let's go Sam
David Duchovny as the Hulk over the past
decade or so three different actors have
played the iconic angry green guy Eric
Bana landed the role in angley's brainy
2003 Hulk butt up did not to return for
a sequel possibly because there were
rumors it would be released
direct-to-video when Marvel decided to
reboot the Hulk David Duchovny
reportedly had the part locked up
according to an AOL interview of
Marvel's then vice-chairman Peter Cuneo
ultimately Ed Norton aggressively
lobbied for the part and won Norton left
after one Hulk film to avoid being
typecast according to an interview of
NPR
Marvel replaced him with Mark Ruffalo
again leaving the term lead chill David
Duchovny out of the equation Tom
Hiddleston a store before Tom Hiddleston
brought a villainous Loki to life Marvel
was interested in him for the role of
Thor himself according to an interview
on Chelsea Lately you auditioned for
Thor the actual Thor the character and
you didn't get you belt you got we
worked out and you got yourself beefed
up and then you were rejected coldly
linemen after his screen test
filmmakers realized he was better suited
for the role of Loki Thor's manipulative
half-brother
fortunately fans can still check out his
audition tape which appears as a bonus
feature on the Thor the dark world
blu-ray Alexander Skarsgard as Thor the
Scandinavian star of True Blood
definitely looked the part of the
ancient Norse god of thunder Alexander
Skarsgard made it all the way to the
final round of casting fourth or even
filming a screen test in costume
complete with helmet and Hammer he
really wanted the part but Marvel went
with Australian hunk Chris Hemsworth
instead Jensen Ackles as Hawkeye even
Hawkeye the least famous Lee's popular
and least super-powered of all the
Avengers was a subject of a casting
battle that was harsh
for Hawkeye as it went down the role of
Hawkeye was nearly offered up as a kind
of consolation prize to supernatural
star Jensen Ackles who had auditioned to
play Captain America Marvel executives
liked him there and invited him to
consider playing Hawkeye ackles past
because he couldn't get out of his
arduous supernatural shooting schedule
which is now on his 12th season and has
recently became the longest running
sci-fi show in the US
sorry Smallville thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know who you think should have been
considered for Avengers
a
ship